and they usually do this to Kevin
Samuels too and I did it you know what I
mean I I you know maybe this is what
goes around comes around because I
remember saying and it really didn't hit
me what he was doing until later because
okay I would say well why is he giving
marriage advice he's not married he was
never giving marriage advice not really
anyways
he would look at outcomes and you talk
to so many people you start to see the
outcomes like this type of girl does
this this happens this type of girl does
that that happens tendency these these
type of women so the most traditional
women have this type of outcomes they're
usually married by 25. now does that
mean a hundred percent does that mean
there's not exceptions no but
you see what I'm saying you see what I'm
saying